unser Militär ist richtig mies
ausgerüstet aber sind wir militärisch
wirklich komplett auf die Amerikaner
angewiesen Deutschlands und auch Europas
Sicherheit sind von den USA abhängig
Punkt das heißt aber nicht dass die Amis
hier nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg immer
noch die Fäden in der Hand halten Joe
Biden kann nicht einfach Kanzler Scholz
anrufen und diktieren was er zu tun hat
Deutschland hat sich bewusst für viele
Abhängigkeiten von den USA entschieden
und beide Länder haben lange vom
freundschaftlichen Verhältnis profitiert
die USA haben Jahrzehnte lang vor allem
Sicherheit und Stabilität versprochen in
den letzten Jahren ist genau diese
Stabilität aber ins Wanken geraten und
Deutschland und Europa müssen sich jetzt
überlegen wie sie damit umgehen wollen
kategorischer Antiamerikanismus oder das
reflexhafte auf die USA zeigen wenn z.B
Russland kritisiert wird sind dabei aber
wenig hilfreich wie seht ihr das denn
was wäre denn für euch das ideale
Verhältnis zu den USA schreibt uns mal
in die Kommentare